Sandy is taking a
cab in New York City.
The taxi fare includes a base
charge of $2.50 as soon as you
enter the cab, plus an
additional $2.50 per mile
traveled.
If Sandy starts off
with a $20 bill,
takes the cab for five
miles, and leaves a $1 tip,
how much money will
she be left with?
Well let's first just think
about how much this five mile
cab ride is going to cost her.
So cab-- I'll call
it the cab fare.
So it's going to be $2.50 just
when you get into the cab,
plus $2.50 per mile.
Well she's going
to go for 5 miles--
let me write it this way--
times $2.50 per miles.
So the cab fare here is just
going to be $2.50, this $2.50,
plus 5 times $2.50.
Let's see, 5 times
$2.50, that is $12.50.
So this is plus $12.50.
$2.50 plus $12.50
is going to be $15.
So just the cab fare
And then Sandy gives a $1 tip.
So fare plus tip is going
to be equal to the cab fare
$15 plus $1 which
is equal to $16.
So then answering the
question, how much money
would she be left
with with a $20 bill?
Well we could
write her change is
going to be, she's going
to give a $20 bill,
the fare plus tip
is $16, minus $16.
So she's going to have
$4 left in change.